aretha franklin's family says the
controversial eulogy delivered at the
queen of souls funeral was offensive and
distasteful reverend jasper williams
junior took aim at the black lives
matter movement during last week's
service causing singer Stevie Wonder to
shout out in protest Williams also
suggested that single black mothers
could not properly raise their sons
beautiful and fine as our black women
are one thing a black woman cannot do a
black woman
cannot raise a black boy to be a man
yeah I beg to differ on that when
Franklin's nephew said the family chose
Williams because he spoke at other
family funerals including for Franklin's
father he said Aretha did not discuss
the funeral plans what place did that
have in the midst of a celebration of
Aretha Franklin exactly by the way that
at being offensive and that's the point
that they're making yeah right Vaughn
Franklin said in the statement quote
Reverend Williams spoke for 15 minutes
and at no time did he properly eulogize
her he said it pushed a negative agenda
which the family does not agree with
Williams defended his remarks he told
The Associated Press he respects the
family's opinion saying I understand
that but I'm sorry they feel that way
it's another example of how not to
apologize you yeah I'm giving a good
apology that certainly wasn't it
no people could say he might have raised
some good points but that was not the
place to do it and I think that's why
people are very upset with him today